the Cheez Whiz bird of Oz and a brand
new Wii controller it's episode 12 of
IMG Woody and Buzz Lightyear all grown
up and dora the explorer'
all grown up or as Jessica Alba here is
Star Wars as a classic PC adventure game
my favorite is the 12 pixel slave
costume but let's get down to business
with photo bombs they occur when someone
or something crashes a picture for
instance this lovely couple is enjoying
a romantic night under a full moon
this Halloween is more creepy than you
thought at first
this girl is oh hi this cat is my hero
this is an actual butt toucher and
honestly sometimes the photo bombs just
the fact that the person looks silly I'm
kidding this is a belly bomb if you want
more BuzzFeed collected 25 cats and dogs
photobombing each other if you want to
see them all follow the link to it and
all the images in this show in the
description
GamesRadar married to awesome things
optical illusions and video games
everyone knows Luigi is taller than
Mario but thanks to the Ponzo illusion
they can look about the same size the
square below is moving around circularly
right
no it's crowbars because of you guys
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming is
getting pretty incredible mikail
revealed the fact that the americas are
actually a duck and jake blew my mind
with this color illusion what looks like
a blue and green ring are actually the
same color seriously try it yourself
these girls are sweet but one has a
hairy arm wait what and here's a picture
of me with a moustache because as we all
know moustaches matter
porcelain dolls are usually soft and
sweet but not these the only thing
creepier is the Xbox Kinect if you've
ever wondered how the Kinect works check
out what happens when you view a room
it's in with night vision goggles all
those tiny little dots are its feelers
and on that note I will leave you today
with a medley of humankind's newest
threat Xbox Kinect accidents and on
Friday we've got a really great nerd
wars coming up Mario vs. Link if it's
already Friday click this box to watch
it otherwise click the box to subscribe
to wacky gamer and as always thanks for
watching